[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life
where we sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my co-host dr greg sadler
today we're talking about the paradox of
choice
so what what is the paradox of choice
it's the inability to hurt the
idea that if we have more choice that's
good but then all of a sudden when you
are
presented with a thousand options then
you can't actually choose any single one
yeah we all experience this at some time
i think
in our day-to-day life common example of
this
is when you ask a group of people where
do you want to go for dinner
and you know if you've only got one
place to go
the local pizza restaurant well that's
where you're going you know
but if you've got 20 different
possibilities and you start
putting these out there to people you
know this person wants thai and this
person says well that's
that's good but i really wanted chinese
instead and then this person says no no
we gotta go to that new burger
restaurant and
pretty soon you've got all these
different choices out there and
it turns into quite an ordeal it takes a
lot of time
you know yeah it's one of those like
lovely things about if you want to live
in a small town it's like well
you got two or three places to go yeah
the danger of that and you're right this
is something where it is paradoxical the
danger of that is that you get bored
with the
the too short range of an options that
you have
so you're like oh i got it i got to go
to this place again or you know
when i was a kid we actually only had
four channels that we could get on the
tv because it was before
cable came in and we lived way out in
the sticks so we couldn't get
channel 18 or channel 24 which were like
a revelation
when i was a kid because then we could
watch cartoons during the daytime rather
than only on
on saturdays but you know you had the
the shows that you had
and that was it and if you missed the
show you know you better hope for a
re-run down the line sometime
and you know so we we'd complain about
that and then you think well it's going
to be great if we get more and more
choices
and there was that phenomenon of they i
think they called it 5 000 channels or
500 channels and nothing on when
cable first came in because you had all
this this stuff
and you know we can experience this in
in so many different ways
so what's what's your
like bottom line take on it is it really
a big problem for us
um it can be um
if you let it i guess okay what my big
takeaway is
so that if you're yeah if you're trying
to get to something perfect and you have
a thousand choices and it becomes very
very difficult to actually quantify what
the perfect choice is yeah or even to
just go by
anything that's qualitative to determine
where the different levels would
would be you can mess around with it
forever and you consume a lot of time
and a lot of let's call it brain space
you know so that by the end you might
make a decision just out of exhaustion
and like i don't really want to like
offend anyone but like
we we've got a thousand and one
different types of coffee out there
yeah yeah yeah at one point i was like
well it's folgers
and folgers dark roast and that's about
it you know you might get a couple of
the brands
like that was that was yeah and now
you've got like a thousand and one
different types of coffee risks
which are great you know you can become
like this
connoisseur of coffee but if it's
if it's not like your hobby then
uh it actually presents a problem it's
like well
i don't even know if i'm gonna like this
like some people don't like hazelnut
you're like well it's coffee you grab it
and
all of a sudden it's not what you were
expecting to get yeah and i
i remember the enjoyment
when i like first encountered um
coffees like that that are flavored with
things other than coffee
uh irish cream was a particular favorite
of mine when i was in
college and it was sort of a revelation
oh you can have this
this way right and you feel this sense
of freedom
but then after a while it's it's it's
not really freeing you up
it's it's actually the the feeling is
almost like
not oppressive but you know you
you feel like you you you have to figure
out what the right thing to do is in
these cases and this is like totally
trivial stuff what
what you're gonna put in your cup that's
not a big deal but people
people run into this with all sorts of
other things what car to buy what
clothes to wear
where to go to college um what do you
study
yeah who to date uh who to marry
exactly yeah so the paradox of of choice
well we should talk about this book
right because it became a tagline i
think because of barry schwartz's
book and it's been quite a while since
it came out it's over 15 years
so he he was saying and he was
focusing primarily on on market stuff on
on retail
stuff and he said that uh you know
we we tend to think of choice as a good
thing we want to try to maximize it as
much as possible and then
you know we've got all these different
options and we want to pick the best
option for ourself
but that's actually the wrong way to go
about things that that makes us
less happier paradoxically than
when somebody just puts two or three
options
in front of us so there's this go-to
quote that that people always bring up
something that he said autonomy and
freedom of choice are critical to our
well-being and choice is critical to
freedom on autonomy
nonetheless though modern americans have
more choice than any group of people has
ever had before and thus presumably more
freedom and autonomy
we don't seem to be benefiting from it
psychologically
now what do you think is is that true
that we're
we're not happier than say people in the
1950s
or you know let's let's take something
really determinate you know you go
to a fast food restaurant it used to be
that you basically had the one thing
that they made like mcdonald's made
hamburgers and that was hamburgers
fries milkshakes you know you could get
your hamburger with onions on it or not
but that was basically it
and then they started coming out with
all sorts of other things eventually you
know the filleto fish and
and you know the mcrib and and
started experimenting with all sorts of
other things and then after a while
there's
there's it's like any other place it's
almost like a going into a diner you've
got this massive
menu of potential choices
although you do see that there's a
contracting
now like it goes through the i don't
know if it came it's gone through cycles
yet but definitely like
expanded also there's like you know a
hundred different things in the menu and
nothing like they're pairing it down
it's like well we don't
actually need that like particular angus
burger or that like double angus burgers
yeah
that's that that's true and and you know
i suppose there's sort of a
cycle that restaurants go through with
these things and a lot of it's probably
on based on what sells
or right or what gets them into trouble
but also like when you're producing
these things it
costs you a lot to have all the
ingredients on hand in order to make
sure that you have
all these different choices especially
for a restaurant it becomes
that's true it's another there's a cost
for
having the increased choices
and you know you but to go back to your
answer like okay
were we happier back then versus now
and i think it's kind of like a little
bit of an attention thing
okay if you if you're spending more time
on deciding
exactly what burger or what coffee or
what you know
of the of the things that are
contributing not actually
super important to one's life does that
actually uh
steal kind of vampirically from or
parasitically from those things that are
actually important
yeah so you end up getting less time
to enjoy your stuff or perhaps you have
less attention
to devote to it after you've you've made
your decisions right
right yeah what about i mean what are
some things that are less trivial where
the paradox of choice can be problematic
for us
well i guess you know those things that
actually are going to take up
a lot of our time and kind of like have
a large impact on
the trajectory of our lives we only have
one life to live right
that's right as far as we know um and
uh so you know as we talked about
earlier those things that got more and
more important
the people that you date the the school
that you decide to go to the jobs that
we take
on and this
kind of no please i think with jobs you
could say the jobs we consider
right because you often won't just apply
to one job you'll
i mean you could be at one place and
then you're like oh this other
opportunity looks really great
i'm gonna move from this one to this one
but generally when people are looking
for jobs
they're applying to as many places as
they can i think for example about my
my poor students this is a terrible
economy right now to be
trying to get jobs in or even
internships you know
um it's not really feasible to do too
much internship-wise i suppose unless
you can work remotely
and they will apply to you know
100 different places and then you might
get offers and how do you
how do you you know weigh which one you
should you should have
in a way if you only have one offer two
offers that makes it a nice simple easy
decision for you take the one that
you've got
but if you have 10 different places
saying yeah we'd like you to come in and
you really don't know much about any of
them
you can do a little bit of research but
this is something we're going to talk
about a little bit
later on there are some things where
it's almost like a black box
you can't know enough about it to make a
really well-informed decision and some
people will
sit there and kind of obsess about it
they'll they'll try to
prognosticate and read into little
things that they find here and there
and try to make try to find some way to
make that decision
other people will just you know flip a
coin or i suppose you could roll a
10-sided die if you have 10 different
opportunities
or something like that right or they'll
go through some very
complicated process of rank ordering of
what they think is better and what they
think is worse and
some might just wait to see who calls
them first
sure yeah that's one way like that's a
heuristic that
you know it'll give you a decision it
might not be the best decision if you're
happy enough
like hey all 10 of these i'd be happy
with like whatever
yeah so there's there's you know
um barry schwartz was interested
primarily just in
one one field but we're saying that this
paradox of choice is something that
runs a lot wider transfers across
a number of different domains and it's
been around for a long time it's it's
you know when we look at ancient
literature we can see that
as cultures became
able to afford a lot of choices to
people you think about dining for
example
um the romans and we're talking about
the people who actually had you know
enough resources so we're not talking
about the
the average labor or something like that
but once people had sufficient money
they could actually get bored with all
the different options for eating stuff
that they had out there and the romans
were
ingenious in finding new sauces to make
and new ways to stuff fish inside fish
or things
cook things in different ways you know
um
what was is that the start of a pesky
pescatarian
well no because they were not
pescetarian yeah
i was i was referring to the fish inside
of fish because i only eat fish
oh yeah yes i suppose
i was thinking you're talking about like
the you know people who
supplement vegetarianism with with with
fish
i mean the romans ate pretty much
anything they could
they could get their hands on that was
edible and even some things that weren't
total trivia here but you know we we we
talk about like the lead pipes and how
that wasn't good for them
but one of the ways of adulterating
pepper was
with lead shot too and then grind that
up
and you know that can't have been good
for you either
um so i mentioned all their the drink a
lot of the drinking cups are also
vladimir
yeah the alcohol will leach it just a
little bit yeah
but you know coming back to this they
they had a lot of different choices and
and um
we could also talk about another issues
like with books
um people would acquire these vast
libraries
and then they wouldn't be able to pick
out which book they should read
you know and so they just sit there in
front of all these it was scrolls at the
time
but they'd sit in front of us this wall
and
and i know what that's like myself
because i've got a very large library
and some days i'll be like well should i
should i read this or re-read this
or you know maybe i want to just you
know relax and read some sci-fi
well which author should i read then
it's it's a similar
problem that can can happen in in all
different ways
right and so one of the things i want to
bring in was from the
world of economics is opportunity cost
and so not only can use like okay at
this moment in time
what is the thing that i want to do or i
want to choose at this moment
but also everything that you choose
means that you can't do the other thing
and so there's a cost associated with
every single thing
you choose both in your time and the
resources
like your money to like buy these things
you buy a tv you might not be able to
buy that like leather jacket that you
also wanted
depending on what what your resource
allotments are
and so that's another thing that like
adds on to this
like feeling of unease is like
kind of you know we'll see you know as
we talk about uh procrastination later
it's like we have
several things that we should or have to
do but you can't choose which one to do
because there's a cost that might like
cause the other one to
not have enough time to do it and then
you result in not doing anything
yeah i'll i'll bring in something from
teaching actually
so one of the constant challenges in
teaching college classes
for those of us who you know try to make
our classes pretty interesting and
are kind of broad readers is the fact
that you get you get 15 weeks at best
and probably you're not even going to
get 15 weeks some of the places that i
teach be
the way that they set up their semester
you basically get 12 weeks
and if you're doing like an intro to
philosophy class or an ethics class or
you know must be even worse with like
literature classes for english uh
people or or a history class you know so
many different sources you can only
teach
you know this much and what you'd like
to bring into the class is
way wider so you're constantly if you
bring somebody new in
you have to throw somebody else out and
you've never had enough people in it's
sort of like you know getting to decide
to have a party in
um an apartment that only seats 12
people
somebody else you want to invite one of
your new friends well
somebody else has got to get out of
there and if you want to spend two weeks
on on a particular text well that means
you that you've got to find that week
and take it away from
from somebody else so if descartes is
going to get two weeks this semester
that means maybe
hume goes goes away or mary
wollstonecraft or whoever
whoever it's going to be you know um and
and you feel
so you thank god before you well for me
um
i i was making a bad pun
decart before him yeah don't don't
uh put the card before him oh i got i
get it yeah yeah
human horse aren't close enough i think
to pull that one off you need somebody
who sounds kind of horsey
you know um but you know we have we have
i guess you could say similar things
about who like who you invite to a party
right um we're we're constantly faced
with these sorts of things and you feel
bad
it does make you feel bad right
so what else do we need to say about the
the paradox itself why
you know why why is it a paradox well
good things make us feel
bad in some way i guess that's the
paradox right
yeah and i think it really only like
came to the forefront in the way that
barry schwartz was talking about it
because um with the advent
of uh you know lots of different choices
in consumer and like yeah capitalism
under in the united states um that it
became a thing
you could easily study because you now
had these
like vastly different ways that you
could buy things
and it became a lot more quantifiable
yeah already in the 1950s and 60s they
were using this term marginal
differentiation
to talk about how products would be set
apart from each other
in very trivial ways it could be as
simple as like
the box is red instead of blue you know
but usually there'd be like some tweak
you know like this this uh
lamp is one inch taller
and you know slightly different color or
something like that but then that
produces a situation in which you do
have to choose between all these
these different lines of products
and then and go ahead and that is
expanded
into our modern age with a b testing
especially
if you're no longer working with atoms
and making actual physical products
if you're only working with pixels um
the marginal cost to create you know a
whole bunch of different options for
people becomes
near zero and so now uh one of the big
things about
you know creating websites or social
media or whatnot
is presenting uh to a large group of
people
uh slightly different ways to present
the same data
and through the aggregate of people's
choices figure out what the preferences
are
and uh and then craft things for those
particular people yeah so having more
powerful tools
makes us more susceptible to this right
right
i just thought of something else that's
kind of along these lines and and i
i don't actually succumb to it myself
because i'm kind of a busy guy and
also a little bit lazy but i know that
there's some podcasters
who take a very long time getting uh
podcast episodes done
and when you talk to them the reason is
because you can constantly
tweak it you can try out this filter or
use this effect or maybe you should like
boost this thing this this way
and i mean it could take you all day
long to edit
five minutes if you really really want
to
focus on it in that way so you're saying
because we do a radio show here
at least is our initial medium that is
actually saving us from the illusion of
choice because
there's only so much we can do well i
i admit it i'm a little bit lazy when it
comes to it i get to the point where i'm
like ah that's good enough
you know but but if i was more
conscientious
maybe i would spend an additional hour
or 10 hours or something like that
and it's not going to make it that much
better you know
and there there goes that 10 hours that
i could have spent on something else
you know that the cost for that marginal
increase in utility or
however you want to define that yeah
yeah
so decreases you know like oh
first first 10 minutes you spend
headache you might get half of what you
are is going to make it good and then
you know the next hour only gives you
another ten percent
yeah true so this this is a
philosophy-focused show and we have a
really
i mean other than saying like who we
would have in a philosophy syllabus we
haven't really talked much philosophy
here
why does the paradox of choice matter
for
practical philosophy
uh because it is
about those determining of what is
actually good on in the things that we
actually choose
uh about specifically decision making
and planning
um and also um can generate um
like this thing that we're talking about
this
you know paradox of choice is creating
the satisfaction anxiety
and other effects within us and one of
the you know time-tested questions
within philosophy is
what denotes a good life and if there
are things that
are you know specifically reducing our
good life then we should probably
investigate them and try to find the
core of these issues in order to try to
avoid them
so with this we can say that it's not
choice itself that's a bad thing right
choice choice generally we think is
quite good and we value getting to make
choices
so it's something about the way the
choices are
set up or structured that produces the
the negative effects that lead us away
from
contentment or happiness or whatever it
is that we want is our practical
end so so let's let's pause on that for
a minute
why why does having more choices
uh create this this problem for us
do we need to have like a certain kind
of threshold
where we say okay that's that's enough
choices or or is it is it more of a
dispositional thing like people don't
know how to handle choices well
and maybe you know some deeper
philosophical
analysis of this would help us to handle
choices
better and what do you think i think
both are
ripe for investigation to try to figure
out if there is
some delineation between what is
i guess bad and what is good enough um
or or like taking that to the extent
like
is there something that you should then
prioritize all over
all other things um as well as
uh this this other like the choosing
so you brought up an interesting thing
that schwartz talks about in his book
and you you've brought this up as well
in different episodes like the the idea
of being a satisficer
as opposed to a maximizer and we should
say what that means right so
maximizer you're trying to make the the
best decision possible
uh get get you know if there's some way
of figuring out what the maximum payoff
is going to be
in terms of pleasure or usefulness or
whatever you you have to go for that
right
right and the satisficer as someone that
has
uh a level in which the decision is
satisfactory enough in order to say like
oh
that's good and this is like a trade-off
because
one you're you're prioritizing like
whatever you define as
um the maximizing thing and the other
one is saying
i'm you know maybe maybe the thing that
i'm really
trying to maximize here is time and thus
i need to have a level where like hi
well that i made that decision unless
you feel like that is
the whole idea of time as maximization
it creates a satisficer
yes uh off base you know it's
interesting
that you're bringing up like different
variables or we could call them whatever
we want to call them different factors
different priorities right
and so a maximizer could be understood
in
in two different ways one would be where
like they identify
the one area that they want to maximize
and that's that's it that's going to
drive
what's going on like they're going to
make the most money or they're going to
somehow
have the drink or meal that's going to
provide the most
pleasure in some way or who knows what
but there's a most in some category
and then you could have let's call them
like a super maximizer
you know because the satisficer could
say to them
hey there's more to life than just what
you're focusing on
i kind of want to have it distributed
over a bunch of different things like
you know one of the things one of the
priorities for me is not wasting a ton
of time
on trivial you know increases that
you're
you're requiring me to do here and i
just want to like you know
think about like i'll give you an
example um i had a family member one
time who
got on my case when when peeling shrimp
uh for
for christmas because i wasn't
preserving that tiny little bit of tail
meat there
and i was like come on i know how to i
know how to peel shrimp i've been doing
this since i was a kid
you just peel it throw it in there and
move on to the next shrimp you know
because i want to eat some shrimp
that's that's my goal is to have some
shrimp and cocktail sauce
and you know sit there with with a beer
and i don't want to spend all this time
on like wiggling this tiny little thing
this person had gotten this from some
class or something like that
and now in their eyes i'm being kind of
a philistine or a slob or whatever right
i'm not
maximizing shrimp meat you know and
apparently that that little bit of meat
is supposed to be sweeter or something
like that you know
so let's call it like culinary units i'm
not providing the maximum culinary units
to this
to this operation that we're engaged in
and i'm saying
you know i kind of want to like eat this
shrimp before it gets too late tonight
so there's two variables there and we
could also talk about like you know not
wanting it to be a big deal that's
another
variable so now the maximizer could come
back and say
okay cool we've got all these different
variables let's maximize
all of them yeah which would be
totally exotic you know but
i imagine there's probably some people
like that who think that you can
actually
maximize everything and it's actually uh
rather prevalent in the software
development world
that oh really oh yeah like well
software is all about maximization
especially okay
you have like certain things like either
you're going to maximize for speed or
you're going to
maximize for efficiency and there are
different algorithms to do these things
and once you've chosen the thing that
you want to maximize for
you make it your mission to like strip
out
anything that is going to like slow down
that operation
and and and then this this idea that
extends on
into people's like actual life and how
they live and becomes like this
maximization i know um
several people that really got in the
soylent train
which is a meal replacement that's like
a chalky
which is not nothing it is not people
we swear
and because like oh well i don't have to
cook i don't have to like go
out anywhere it's just yeah it's there
i've got like 30 bottles of this stuff
i just grab one i drink three a day and
i'm good that's like
it's sacrificing all enjoyment that one
would get from actually eating
yeah so it's like okay nutrition is the
only important thing
and i'm going to sacrifice everything
else because i'm just here to cone
wow yeah that that is for me that would
be a massive sacrifice
you know but so so would you say that
there's there's like a mindset
that or maybe there's some some fields
in which
there are mindsets that make us more
susceptible to thinking that
optimization is what we need to do
or maximization oh absolutely and
like as i said like especially uh
engineering and software
like that's your entire job is is
finding
better ways of doing things faster
cheaper like
less resource intensive ways of doing
things and then
making them automatic okay
i wonder what other fields would be this
may be something we talk about later on
but maybe there's there's other fields
that are particularly susceptible to
that where
perfectionism is a a uh key component
you know and i've fallen into it a
little bit like i i cook once a week
okay and i put everything in in
tupperware dishes because
um like i don't want to spend all that
much time on cooking but i do
like tasty food and i found a couple
recipes that
i really enjoy and i've been eating
literally for years now
like you know breakfast lunch and dinner
i eat the same thing most days of the
week
um but they're all very tasty and so i
yeah
i i think about a little bit of a middle
ground
yeah you know and something else i think
that people do this with is clothing
right
you can get really into fashion which
which has never been
something attracting me uh in part
because i always saw it as kind of a
waste of money and a
waste of time since things go out of
fashion so quickly
but you could get into that and and like
you know obsess about having this thing
and it has to match with this thing over
here and
uh it could be quite difficult to make
make choices about what to wear
then you could be at the other extreme
it'd be steve jobs who deliberately
you know he said that he deliberately
wore the outfit that he had so he
wouldn't have to think at all about what
he was going to
to wear sort of like olive oil the
cartoon character there's a
scene where she opens up her her closet
and it's all the same dress
that's almost become a trope with
especially cartoons
i feel like i've seen that scene that
same scene several times
that it's probably the case but it
probably does come from
popeye i'm imagining because it's such
an old cartoon
you know and it's nice too because
you're like well i guess she at least
changes her clothes
so you know if you think about cartoons
total digression but if you think about
cartoon characters they're always
wearing the same thing right
it could be that they never actually
change their clothes which
from a personal hygiene perspective
that's not not a good thing
good good thing we don't have
smell-o-vision on the cartoons maybe
they stinked really terribly
continuing on with like this choice and
like you know
one uh in philosophy
depending on the different way schools
if you have like a school like the
epicureans which are
the basic hedonistic ideas of like
pleasure and pain defining what is good
or bad
um this is a way or a tool or a
heuristic to try to
solve some of these things um and then
also
like trying to choose between the
different things that we we might think
are valuable
um depending on if they are or not um
you know our time our relationships our
tastes our enjoyment
our money on experiences these are all
things that you could potentially
if you want to try to maximize or at
least like give a couple of them
priority
over others yeah so that actually leads
us
into some of the other dark sides of the
paradox of choice
because you can try to maximize right
but you're you're going to fail and
you may disappoint yourself in the
process because you you really want to
put
you know this amount of work and time
and into
maximizing but you don't do it and then
you feel
you feel bad about yourself you feel
like you made the wrong choice
or you made a choice that wasn't
reasonable for you to make
at the time and there's a number well
let's let's talk about some of these
dynamics
one of them is this old phrase the grass
is greener on the other side
and you know when we have real things
that we've chosen there's sometimes a
tendency to
look at the imperfections look at the
ways in which it's not optimal and to
you know see something else
you know so if we want to use this
metaphor you look at your grass it's
easy to see where there's dandelions and
you know brown patches or you're more
cut too
too low and you look at your neighbor's
grass which is a little bit further away
you can't see the imperfections quite so
well and you're like oh it's probably
better over there you know
and we say this about jobs we say this
about relationships we say this about
all sorts of
things you know so a person can think oh
i made the wrong choice
i should have chosen this and i chose
this other thing instead and now i'm
stuck with this choice and then they
they feel bad about the good thing that
they actually have
you know which is not a perfect thing
but at least is good in many respects
you can and this could happen in a
restaurant i mean you could be sitting
there you've got your meal in front of
you and you
you look across you're like oh i should
have ordered what that person ordered
right right and
you know once you made your decision you
should probably
sit with the decision at least for a bit
you know like there should probably be
like oh i want to talk about like local
maxima and vino
um but if you've got like a graph of
like
enjoyment and you're going to get to um
you're going to get to like some
homeostasis which would be like a local
minima there's probably
there's a cost to go to any uh other
you know local minima you're gonna have
to explain that for our
our listeners i think right okay so
um so we make made a choice
and now there's a cost associated with
changing
any of these choices so once you made a
choice um
there should be a really good reason to
actually
like make a big choice to change like so
we're at the restaurant i've just spent
you know twenty dollars on a meal
all of a sudden like well that thing
looks really great over there are you
gonna just like throw out 20
worth of food and say like no give me
that as well as the time it takes to
prepare that it's like yeah
um and and like
i don't think there's a problem in
making different decisions
but you you should probably figure out
what is the cost that one wants to incur
and then we're actually to make that uh
decision
you know another factor that fits in
with that as well
is if you chose a meal right the meal is
not going to
get upset that you didn't eat it because
it doesn't have any consciousness
but if you chose to be
involved in a relationship with this
person and then you're like oh i think i
should have gone with that person
instead
if you do that then you you are probably
going to hurt some feelings unless
they're happy to see you go on you know
if they realize that you were a bad
choice yourself or something like that
um but you know and we could say this
about work relationships too you know if
you
you started a company and you're like oh
i don't really like it here that much
i think i'll go to that other place
instead you're going to create some ill
will
right yeah except for a
little tangent um apparently uh zappos
who uh the founder of which
had this policy of like coming to an
employee
like a month after they started and so
like
here's a thousand dollars if you quit
wow
and so it basically
said i'm giving you an out it's totally
fine if you don't like the job
here's some money it'll hold you off for
a couple months until you get a new job
um no no hard feelings no ill will
because the only one of the people that
were actually
really really wanted to work there and
so like it makes sense that like
you're you're not stuck with this bad
decision yeah as well
and it's beneficial really to
both parties the employer and the
employee that's that's really
interesting
there did he have like stats on like how
many employees
took the thousand dollars and left did
he ever say that or
not that i saw but apparently since
amazon bought them
amazon has taken this idea at least to
some parts of his company
interesting it's almost like um
they're offering you a severance package
right
yeah but it's it's really early on yeah
wow that's it's an interesting thought
it sure is
yeah so so philosophy can help us in
in figuring these these matters out and
we're not going to like commit ourselves
to any particular school of philosophy
but there's sort of a meta problem here
and that you probably
do need to pick one you know it could be
an epicurean or you could be a stoic or
you could
you know follow something else you don't
want to have to like pick and choose
between all the different available
philosophical positions
you know which one is going to be the
basis for making these
decisions because that would just kick
the problem up to a higher level
you're probably better off picking
something and experimenting with it
right
right um and so like
one of the things is we often use
heuristics to make decisions and and
these are
also known as like cognitive biases that
you know
these heuristics are really good because
you know a lot of them actually results
in good outcomes
a lot of the time like they're they're
good enough for
us and our ancestors who've like gone
through our lives and and
got enough food and shelter and
procreated to to
now have the current crop of humans
floating around that we are
um but they also can result in us
having really bad outcomes but like it's
kind of a rule of thumb it works like 90
of the time
and that's good enough for most of the
people yeah
and and so we can we can use heuristics
and and some of the
ideas from these particular schools of
thought are also heuristics
um it's like you know if you're
epicurean if it's pleasurable that's the
way that that's your heuristic
you know you go towards the pleasure and
go away from the pain it's it's pretty
you know straightforward that way
but it is is useful to reassess these
heuristics once you've chosen them and
so you know say you say you want to try
out being
um you know a platonus or an
aristotelian or a
stoic or a epicurean um
try try like out
trying to make these decisions based on
these uh particular
schools of thought and see how you like
it yeah you know
with with modern stoicism there is and
we've gone through it already this
year um stoic week which used to be
called live like a stoic week
and the idea behind it was they would
they would give you like a handbook
that each day had a couple you know
reading selections and some exercises
and
it would have you engaging in some some
reflection about your life and your
decision making and
and you would try it out just like
you're saying you would
apply it and then see whether it made
any changes in your overall mood or
whether you'd made
better decisions and prioritizations or
whether you'd had any
you know insights or things like that
and we could imagine doing this
maybe there should be like you know
starter packs for for
all these different philosophies you
know if you want to
give this a shot and see how it how it
helps you
zero in on what's important for you
because you know one of the things that
you're you're
saying here is that if you do pick a
particular approach to things it at
least narrows this
range of choices down some choices are
just going to be totally
uh irrelevant at that point right you're
not going
you're not going to consider them you're
not going to worry about them
afterwards you're not going to
for example you know so one of the other
things i wanted to talk about is a
recent phenomenon called
fomo or fear of missing out that a lot
of people
have which seems to have gotten a lot
worse because of social media
you know people see their friends on
instagram
or twitter or facebook or whatever else
it's going to be
doing things they're like oh man i could
be enjoying that right now and put aside
the fact that a lot of the stuff is just
fabricated
you know it's done with all these
filters and you know id you know
70 photos before you get the perfect
selfie
in front of the the meal that you're
having or stuff like that
right put all that that nonsense aside
there's still this worry that by
engaging in what i'm doing right now i'm
missing out on on something else
and there are some philosophical
approaches that would i mean
even just stuff that doesn't have to get
particular feel particularly
philosophical and just says hey
live in the moment you're in eat the
food in front of you right now
or be with the person that you're you're
you know across the table from
that would be helpful but when we get to
substantive
philosophical approaches i think there's
there's more room for
curbing fomo or the grasses greener
thing
or the kind of paralysis that can happen
in
trying to make decisions for so many
people
yeah the whole idea of having
some rules that you're trying to
that that are set out for you on to
try to live your life by uh
helps one make decisions better and be
more content with the decisions that
they've made
yeah i think there's also a critical
aspect to
philosophy you know when we look at our
own society
it is probably tougher for us with
respect to the paradox of choice than it
was people 20 years ago in part because
of the proliferation of
um ways that you know mobile technology
and the internet
and um everything being mediated through
through computers
uh allows us to do so much more and have
so many choice so many more choices
in front of us right
so you know philosophy can can
sort of clue us in and it's not the only
discipline that can do that to the how
how vulnerable we've we've made
ourselves in in the culture that we're
we're in and then we can identify oh
maybe maybe this is actually not a
situation i need to be in where i need
to choose between 20 different things
maybe this would be a better thing for
me to just pick
pick one particular thing and and uh
stick with it
or near maybe deliberately narrow my
range of choices
maybe that's the thing to do in some
cases
so you know one of the studies the case
studies that was
done by uh in regards to like this
paradox of choice is
grocery stores like trader joe's or aldi
which has a significantly
reduced amount of options for any
particular thing i was like oh
they're salsa but there's only like four
options
instead of like a hundred and they're
all the same brand right generally yeah
yeah pretty much you know some things
might have
a brand name here or there but like for
the most part it's like it's a store
brand
you know here's the one you got yeah
pick it or not
uh and people uh you know flock to these
stores
for you know this and other reasons but
um there's definitely some studies that
said that there are there are benefits
from having
a reduced choice in that
yeah you know the prototypical product
with perhaps too many choices
is spaghetti sauce you know you've got a
lot of different brands
right and some of them you know are
oriented towards different kinds of
consumers
um like you know paul newman gives a
certain amount to charity right so if
you like charity okay then that that
fits in there and there could be like
some local brands
that you're like you have a an
attachment to because you want to
support
local uh spaghetti sauces i don't know
of any for wisconsin
there must be something somewhere um but
so many of them like the paul newman or
classico
or or whatever it's going to have like
anywhere from like
six to 20 different sauces
that you can have and maybe the maybe
the way to approach that
is you say okay i'm not i'm not going to
look at all these sauces
i'm just going to think about the brand
that i want and i'll
only choose within that range or i'll
say i only want
sauces that have mushrooms and black
olives
and and i'm not going to consider
anything else maybe that's
the way to handle some of that over
variety
right yeah okay here actually we should
think about this in sort of practical
problems um another big one that a lot
of people have wasted a ton of time on
is with netflix or hulu or any of these
streaming services they offer you all
these different options
and some people will take
an extraordinary amount of time so much
that they don't get to watch anything
deciding what they're going to watch is
there is there
is there a way to get yourself out of
that
whatever we want to call it that trough
or bucket
where you've got all these different
things in front of yourself there's a
way to climb out of that
so that you can produce a good situation
for yourself
i know maybe you have got one director
that you like and just like oh i'm just
going to watch everything that he makes
but that's just a heuristic you know
yeah
in a way it's it's reducing your
autonomy to say okay i'm going to make a
rule and stick with that
right but it's the rational thing to do
in many cases
right okay bringing it back to
philosophy like
aristotle has this like this golden mean
and like between like
being a coward and and going and
fighting a thousand people all by
yourself you know
yeah yeah it's foolish you know you
might
think it's like courageous but it's like
courage
yeah on and so maybe we take this idea
of the golden mean
and also bring it to you here is okay
have a heuristic you work with it until
it doesn't feel right anymore
and then maybe you pick a new heuristic
or a new way to
constrain yourself okay
yeah i've seen satisficers talked about
as similar to aristotelian moderation
i wonder too if we couldn't say that
it's also similar to
temperance or self-control you know
deliberately restricting yourself
instead of saying i'm going to have it
all
not having it all of course but having
it all sort of impossibility
you say um i know that i'm
liable to fall into what you know
not even watching anything but just
scrolling through different movie titles
for
um half the length of a movie
so i'm going to deliberately make a
decision to to not do that you know
maybe i'll just get like a a list and
then go down that list of movies
you're wanting to talk about uh the
pragmatist view of this
oh yeah so there are
a lot of uh decisions this is something
that william james says in the
the will to believe but a lot of
philosophers have talked about this
before
james and many after there's a lot of
decisions
where we we can't really know
what we're getting ourselves into unless
we jump into it and he gives examples of
like taking a job
or getting involved with a romantic
partner
if he says he's got a great little
vignette in there where this person is
skeptical about whether the other person
truly loves them or not and he says you
know if you don't like uh
take some of this on faith and then like
make some moves
you're never actually going to find out
whether they do like you or not
you have to go on a date you have to you
have to do something with them right
uh if you're if you're going to wait for
like complete confirmation
before you you leap well you'll never
you're never going to leap
and i think there's a lot of things like
that and i think that
part of what james is saying there is we
shouldn't be stupid or foolhardy or you
know
go off as they say half cocked but we
should give ourselves permission
to get into things and realize that they
they're they're you know so much of life
is really an experiment
and some of it's going to go wrong um
and that's not
you know provided we didn't do any
stupid uh
decision making at the start provided we
were you know being fairly rational
given the best information we had
there's nothing wrong with that it's not
it's not something we have to feel
regret about
um i mean unless we say things like you
know i wonder what it would be like to
kill and cook a human being okay now
james would say don't do that right you
know
but when it comes to these other things
uh ways of resolving the paradox of
choice maybe we should be
more pragmatic and experimental about it
and not place um
you know not place a heavy burden on
ourselves and then when we
when we start doing negative self-talk
like saying oh we're so stupid to make
this choice
you know i should have done that thing
over there maybe we have to talk back to
that
that negative self-talk and say i made
the best decision at the time that
given the information i had you know
this reminds me of the idea of the map
is not the terrain
okay uh you know we looking at options
before we take it
actually experience them fully where
we're seeing a
a grainy version of the actual reality
of the situation
and uh you we we get to realize that
we can make all these decisions based
off these outside looking in
experiences um but until we're actually
inside
there's a whole gamut of of different
experiences
that we may or may not like and there's
only one way to actually find out
yeah and and i think that there's so
many
areas where that is the norm
one of the ones i wanted to talk about
was choosing a college to go to
i ask my students quite often in classes
well why did you pick this college to go
through and they'll give me some reasons
and then i'll say well how did you know
that that was actually going to be the
case
and they said well uh you know i saw it
in the college brochure and i said
they all you know all these college
brochures basically look the same they
all
say that this is a wonderful academic
environment
they have you know happy shiny people on
the front you know on a bright day
sitting in the quad
they're all basically cut from the same
cloth right and they'll they'll have
buzz words in there like quality
education and
small class sizes or whatever it's going
to be study with world-renowned scholars
you have no idea that you're going to
get any of that stuff
when you go to any particular college
because it could be that the
world-renowned researchers they're on
sabbatical that year
you know or it could be like now where
uh whatever place you picked
uh they're dealing with covid yeah so
you really have almost no idea what
you're getting into
and i think it's easy to it's easy to
wind up in that that like fear of
missing out or
thinking the grass is greener somewhere
else if we're not careful so we we have
to be
prudent about about these sorts of
things and we have to say well
you know you can try to acquire
information like the best way to find
out about colleges
is not to talk to the tour guide it's to
like go off of the tour
and like wander in and ask people what
they think of the place
then eventually the tour guide will
corral you and bring you back and start
you know yammering at you about how
great this this place is or this place
is
um but you know even then you can't get
you can't get full information i think
we can say the same thing about jobs
you take a job in a company you know
you've done
a couple interviews with them maybe
you've done your due diligence but you
you don't really know what that
company's
uh like deep down inside you know
we very infrequently
get the ability to control uh variables
in a scientific manner in order to
really
come down to the heart of the issue and
to compare
two or more choices and say like this
definitively
is this way or the other and um and
especially for
the it's the worse it is the larger the
decision like i can
try out a thousand different on tomato
sauces and potentially find one that i
have definitively
decided that i will like and that's what
i'm going to eat for the rest of my life
um but you can't try out a thousand
different colleges there's
there's just that's right that's right
yeah
yeah and um shout out to alfred uh
krizsky
for the map territory relationship oh
right right yeah the general semantics
people
yeah yeah that's yeah this is totally
off topic but
there's actually a science fiction
author
who has an institute for general
semantics in his stories it's a
van vote and he has this world of null a
he was really impressed by by that
movement
and he built that philosophy into
his uh his novels um so there's
it's way off in the future the the
institute is like developed and all that
i think it actually gets nuked at one
point
yeah so we we did want to talk about as
we usually do
some sort of uh practice that you can
apply in your
everyday life um we'd be remiss if we
didn't get to that
so do you want to lead us through that
sure and so we've been kind of beaten
around this bush this entire hour
so the the practices investigate what is
truly valuable
and then apply so one of the basic
questions philosophy is
what do we or should we value is there a
hierarchy of values or a delineation
between these things
that have value and those things you do
not and
you know depending on the school of
thought there are different answers to
this question
but the biggest thing is to investigate
some of them
choose one apply that choice and
and be pragmatic as we're talking about
like they'll live like a stoic week
you know just try out the stoic
practices live like it
record your like feelings about how you
enjoy that maybe that's for you
maybe it's not maybe the epicureans are
better to fit you
and your proclivities you know i'm going
to bring up william james
again as well here he thought that a lot
of philosophy
was a matter of uh temperament that
you know he was what we call a pluralist
he didn't think that there was just one
philosophical
path that was completely right and he
thought that people were
attracted to and found different
philosophies useful for themselves
because of
we could call it whatever part of their
personality their temperament
but the idea was that not everything is
for every single person
some some approaches are going to be
more productive
for for some people and and i don't
think we should feel bad about that
i think we should we should give
ourselves again permission to like
experiment and see what works for us and
then
apply it yeah it's
it's kind of like the human condition
hopefully you've got
the wherewithal to to try things and try
to find
that yeah the niche that the niche that
like fits you as well as possible
yeah and it could be kind of like a
feedback thing right how do you know
that something is really going to work
for you
it doesn't just like immediately hit you
in the face and say boom this works
perfectly across the board
you got to work at it a bit and practice
and then it like reveals something to
you
and then you're like oh now i get it and
then you do some more stuff and then
it rewards you some more you know or
maybe challenges you or
or whatever you know and and so it's a
continual dialectical process
and it seems like a lot of people kind
of go through this in their teenage
years they try out a whole bunch of
different persona
or things that they think they're going
to like and then and we kind of solidify
them so yeah
i did enough investigation i'm good with
what i've got and
i would say you should
maybe not do it as much as a teenager
but like
you need to uh open yourself up to the
at least the opportunity
that's a great that's a yeah i like that
that's that's a great way to think about
it
sort of a moderate approach right you
don't have to you know suddenly open up
every single possibility
uh that would be opening up pandora's
box quite literally
the box of evils but you but you
yeah you should be open to doing more
and
so this leads us to our ending quote do
you want to take us
out on on this one okay from voltaire
in his writings a wise italian says the
[Music]
best
[Music]
you